deixem me dizer que estou bastante
nervoso que falar
uma câmera em casa o estúdio e estar
aqui hoje com vocês
obrigado anterior embora é um e quero
falar em um caso como é que és o
atlético mudou completa minha vida é
ajudou a mudar por completo a minha vida
é em que umas mas nem tudo começou aqui
então vamos passar aqui esse foi meu
primeiro computador e e em muitos de
vocês já conhecem estamos nesse espectro
em que tinha é e provavelmente
muitos meus seguidores mais novos hoje
seus mostrar isso e nos perguntamos que
isto mas isso faz parte da minha
infância é cassete e e quer mostrar o
quanto isto foi tudo muito importante na
minha vida e o que eu faço hoje
agora então é assim este vídeo mostra
espero que eu não eu nunca isto é só
para mostrar que é estar no início do
jogo é que o computador não existe
espectro que eu jogava e em é um carro
para mostrar que os jogos que vimos hoje
tudo que temos hoje no digital é tudo
muito bonito mas não tinha nenhum quando
diante de monte não vai conseguir não
embaixo da aspas aspas reparem como
estão indo e o jogo pois iniciava com um
gambá do código gastar com um gravador
com o jogo jogar isto agora começa um
novo todo jogo vai ser lindo pois não
tem paciência para esperar por um jogo
mesmo até programada na flexão
mas isto era o que os gava horas e horas
e horas do fim e só para fazer um cada
vez de ligação com o youtube na questão
que até hoje não apareceu na minha vida
por causa disso este primeiro computador
desse espectro mudou completamente minha
vida porque eu passei muitas horas fazem
muitas cópias gasset vai envolver o
nível gráfico e estou indo para que a
gente até tinha dificuldades em perceber
o que era um jogo mas pronta que anuncia
prova e é um pecado e era um caso assim
agora ok depois passei anos as músicas
cópias músicas em mp3 na pista dessas
coisas todas que muito certo vocês sabem
o que é
na altura ia comprar a música em cd no
formato de cd e giro eu fico estarrecida
com isso que ocupe muito jogar com muita
música e depois passamos aqui os anos 90
em que o pronto aqui já começa tudo
fazer mais sentido
começamos a ter internet estamos a ter
um navegador quero estar à vista em que
revelam uma página por si uma imagem
pois é isto é o que é hoje e egito
eu tenho passado dessa fase neste
crescimento por exemplo meu filho chegar
a provisão em educar porque eu acho que
é tudo tátil né e engraçado ter passado
de ter visto esse crescimento todo em
termos de tecnologia e este é o meu
primeiro telemóvel estamos a falar dos
anos 2000 entre uma coisa fantástica ao
topo pias ou seja ir a vacaria e punha
quatro pilhas e o estado mais máscaras
meus amigos não ligava para gravar cinco
minutos de harry turmas podem desistir
de vir e sá quatro pilhas duracell a
espetáculos da espetacular
convém é lindo por antena também puxava
e parte da frente que em w ou seja a
gente andava assim não é comandamos hoje
com telemóvel assim mostrar o símbolo da
maçã não andamos assim ela é
completamente franco mas também era mais
seguro traz os problemas com segurança
mais fácil depois é parece os primeiros
jogos nos telemóveis e acho que toda a
gente tem mais ou menos a meio das
garrafas nem que falei que era o jogo
que hoje nós passamos na casas bahia ver
os filhos no facebook não sei que antes
não era jogar sei que todos os gastos
médicos e então isso é bom pra mim é
mágico deixe-me dizer que pra mim mas
chover esta voltar a ver estas imagens é
mais que vive muito isso e acho que esse
3310 provavelmente foi muito mais
vendido da nokia por toda a gente tinha
e era bastante consistente e adorava uma
semana o time hoje em dia não é nós
chegamos à noite é tipo sair do caso tem
provocado por um carro tem que ter uma
um carregador também o fórum é isto só
para demonstrar que
a tecnologia como é hoje eu vivia muito
com vocês com certeza mais ou menos a
minha idade os mais novos têm muita
dificuldade em que eu fico feliz e que
esta é uma imagem
quando aparece o primeiro smartphone que
eu compro primeiro smartphone em que eu
gostava tanto do mundo android que era
um sistema operativo permite fazer
muitas alterações e eu ficava o cofre
onde existe os meus amigos me fizeste e
então diga sim nem estar a falar 15
vezes a mesma coisa tem que arranjar um
sistema para poder colocar em alguma
delas vão haver ea equipe aparece tudo
que eu faço isto sem querer mesmo com os
vídeos se falar em ataque que é isto o
que for passado o tempo começa a ver com
os vídeos vão assistindo ou seja não era
só os meus amigos meus familiares por
quando começa um canal do youtube as
pessoas que vão ver os seus amigos ea
sua mulher que o resto ninguém que
conheça mas sem querer eu fiz vídeos de
coisas que eram pesquisar vestir como
mudar o papel de parede como formatar
como importar os contatos do outro
telemóvel eua e então e é aqui que surge
um canal no youtube mas sempre com um
conteúdo esporádicos quer dizer que eu
tenho meu trabalho e fazer isso ao final
do dia ou à noite ia fazendo estava
vivendo aqui o estado à altura que não
ganhava dinheiro com o youtube é que nos
encaminha fazia mesmo pela paixão de
partilhar conteúdo é que eram os meus
primeiros vídeos que nem parecia via
pessoas que perguntavam não existe algum
busto do tef que já tinha montam viciava
que mo nunn china vá enfrentar mas são
busca colocar méxico pois é só mexer com
esta etapa tal maneira pessoas me
perguntavam mas não é minha mão mesmo às
vezes envia mensagens que diziam
atravessam sérias precisam para ganhar
as mensagens dos primeiros vídeos eu
nunca passe mesmo tanto é que o canal
não chamava no dia que o meu nome e que
era um espaço onde já fazia numa divisão
é o meu conteúdo daquilo que eu estava
eu passava as noites ano neste espaço o
que acontece nesta nesta fase que eu vou
publicando alguns vídeos de exemplares
em português como até formatar o pc
coisas funcionaram até com com windows é
que começa a ponderarem eu passei para
elton que está mesmo isto o que está a
fazer os vídeos do que está a partilhar
e neste esta é uma imagem de um vídeo
dessa altura mas aqui uma mudança que é
que eu fazia na altura muito restritiva
não faço
é fácil ver é e então eu comecei a ter
bastantes dores musculares pensei que
era talvez o chefe de justiça
fui é que isso já é passado algumas
algum algumas unidades hospitalares
nesta unidade hospitalar
eu fui lá já aconteceu porque o próximo
parceiro certo marítimo nas pessoas
porque já estava com o tesouro estava
com muita dificuldade em andar e ninguém
conseguia perceber o que era han
até que nesta que nesta nesta unidade
hospitalar e que podem vir a estar o
mais nem na batina disseram mais cedo
que estão nas pernas então não conseguia
movimentar mas quer que a última
consultas artilheiro cobrou falta
ninguém sabia já tinha tomado muita
dedicação já estava curtindo anos estava
tomando muita coisa e é que nesta semana
o médico diz assim no bairro de ficar
aqui balsa seis anos todos por vastos
por cima com mangueiras de frente até fã
mas fiquei lá uma semana e conseguiram
um diagnóstico da tuberculose ganglionar
tomar posse mas tentou falar é
transmissível como nos prontos a uma
medicação não comentaram os de outras
pessoas e que era muscular ou seja os
músculos e não conseguia ter reação e o
próximo passo era músculos de bull
pressão e ou seja não estaria aqui
certas esta semana não te faças exames
fui a várias captações para ver por
causa de profissionais que ensinam êxito
e este sinal que eu tenho aqui foi o que
salvou a vida foi de 9 11 tratado e
depois comecei a ter a companhia de si -
todas as minhas branco 12 comprimidos
todos os dias durante um ano nessa
altura baixa em casa e eu pensei o que
vou fazer vou ficar verão as manhãs da
juventude ficou maluco é a mulher chegar
a casa já não posso mesmo falar do mesmo
mês
e eu penso assim bem vou começar a fazer
vídeos porque eu pude fazer um vídeo
para os vídeos eu estou sentado ou
sentadas não sabem se têm problemas não
têm e era o meu escape paz fácil que é
bom não podendo comprometer tanto dos
santeiros dois cavaletes e é que o banco
também que não está
bem vou fazer os vídeos aqui fica o
destino a dar ao time a minha canon e
estamos cara difícil mas e então começa
a fazer vídeos tudo e mais alguma coisa
portanto fazer triagem então comecei a
fazer tudo máquinas essa frase o estudo
tippi hedren turno essa casa máquina faz
muito bem porque com uma semana será a
fala daquela visão e é a minha mulher
teve que não é pontuar que eu tenho nem
as coisas vocês entendam é você fazer
vídeos aquela está uma máquina da taça
coca cola foi um vídeo muito funcionou
muito bem isso nesta altura o canal
argumentou posso dizer que toda essa
dívida é mais um milhão resoluções mas
funciona também o seu sono com as
grandes gastal possam dar a tua vida é
de fazer um vídeo tudo pode até fazer um
vídeo com uma pessoa tem que pensar
assim
do outro lado portar uma pessoa pode ter
o poder de mudar a sua vida e às vezes
as suas leis tanto isso não interessa
para mim o bom do disto é fazer o salto
bastasse o tupi me permitiu um salva era
sobre oscar mas não as pessoas poderão
visitar não havia muitas visitas e nesta
altura que estou fazer todos os vídeos
ea durar tudo mas uma coisa está a
chegar a altura que ficavam taxa chegar
a altura que a minha baixa vai terminar
eu tenho que pensar ou continua a fazer
o trabalho que eu tinha como qualquer
outra pessoa a cada dia se não gosta
daquilo que faz que um bom humor na
dutra sempre trabalhei com informática
mas pensei mas é aquilo que eu quero
fazer é que chegado engatar já tô com o
fim da minha mãe é minha e eu só fui
muito disso e e pensei não vou pois o
clube ser feliz na que o que eu faço nos
permite ter também muito tardiamente fez
bem remunerados até às duas resoluções e
então claro que eu percebi que estava as
pessoas podem lá é o canal ainda hoje e
permite obter por exemplo metal e trouxe
um bilhete coisas incríveis o que eu
quero dizer é que o youtube está lá com
este brutal crise a ponto mas tanto pra
mim tá pra qualquer um de vocês e eu
quero dizer aqui eu não dei a minha
mulher porque ela não faz ouvir falar em
alto mar
toda a gente está a fazer alguma coisa e
youtube quando começa a ter visibilidade
meus amigos pode transformar nossa vida
e eu não é verdade é que eu nunca estive
tão mais gostou na hora então não querem
forma física existe melhor mas em tudo o
resto eu sou muito mais feliz do que eu
faço não tem intenção nenhuma de que o
faz minhas pessoas incríveis todos os
dias basta vir a roubar as pessoas
colocarem tudo às vezes até fixa está
mas o que eu queria dizer aquilo que
isto mudou minha vida em tudo tudo e
acho que com este exemplo que eu estou
lá é a satisfazer uma cadeira como
prédios fazem partilhar simplesmente
quer ver isso e eu quero dizer aqui é
perfeitamente possível no início quando
você fazer isso não havia dinheiro no
youtube e hoje em dia é possível ter uma
visão mais clara da trabalhos pesados
têm muitas vezes só se um vídeo passar
dois dias em 300 mil e 400 mil adesões
até chegar ao trabalho às 10 da vida dar
uma chapada com a história da doença e
portanto isto sim e esta e esta cicatriz
aqui em casa com quem foi a vida a dizer
num lugarejo tive essa sorte eu
reconheci tive essa sorte também poderão
ser acessados aqui e minha mulher que
ela estava mais feliz não só isso mas eu
adoro o que eu faço
youtube mudou a minha vida e se você
olhar o tempo total há muito a fazer
isto é complicado com as suas caras
todos aqui à frente mas a mensagem eu
queria passar é que um é perfeitamente
possível nós serão os fluídos e às vezes
temos até o fim do youtube segura e eu
posso dizer que não há limites neste
momento para tudo que faz e amanhã
quiser fazer um vídeo com macedo 500 mil
anos eu consigo fazer isso pudessem
estar cinco anos atrás
assim vai ter possibilidade de falar por
exemplo a marca com 800 e os pães um
cartucho 500 mil anos a porta para fazer
um vídeo de um nunca na vida
só que eu quero dizer é que como está
aqui o botão do piloto
vocês têm certeza que sabem fazer alguma
coisa e começa reis o meu nome é da
minha espero que vocês tenham gostado
fique bem como nos vídeos
fui é escutar obrigado